hey guys it's Inka today we're gonna be
doing something a little bit different
my friend des gave me an ostrich egg he
challenged me to make a giant egg
mcmuffin haha we only have one ostrich
egg it is not a cheap egg the stakes are
very high but let's make it work we're
gonna start off by making the English
muffin part so I looked up some recipes
and I made the dough last night
so here's the no flower moment of truth
[Music]
look at how much hair this hair I'm
gonna need this gently oh so smooth I
need to roll this out now roll it like
pizza
[Music]
that looks pretty decent
they said sprinkle pretty generously I
think I'm being very generous it smell
so good
[Music]
OhLaLa Cicero looks like very now this
is the muffin we're gonna let this proof
for a little over an hour and we can
start working on the ostrich egg yeah
like I trying to play it very smooth
even though it has bigger pores than I
do
[Music]
it's beginning of crap oh my god the
membrane why is it so full
[Music]
[Music]
it looks like egg that was the hardest
part I'm gonna pour this in the mold now
I'm gonna put it in the oven okay oh my
god is leaking oh my god we're gonna go
350 maybe a little lower
okay let's check home time later we're
going to transfer this huge piece of
bread to the cast iron how does one
transfer this no lololo
wow that was a complete and utter place
we're just gonna wait now until it
becomes golden brown I think it's about
that time
Wow put it on this we eat it maybe she
pop it in the oven bye bye see you later
it's all coming together now our
beautiful ostriches
so excited so while I'm waiting for
these to cool down I am going to pan fry
these super thick cut hook by thick I
mean damn is just perfect for a giant
egg McMuffin Wow okay so you're only
supposed to open these with a fork so I
found a giant fork ish thing a shy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so happy so we're gonna butter these
slices up make it extra grease the extra
yummy and these are going back in the
oven
so we're gonna do the most important
part now we're research purposes the
original Egg McMuffin you see the bread
on top the ham the ng so that's how
we're gonna build ours here we go
I could not find a giant piece of cheese
so we're gonna have to do this one bite
what this is the moment we've been
waiting for done dessert Wow how do you
take this off we're gonna put the ham
I'm gonna cover it up and this my
friends beautiful giant egg bacon but
the only thing missing is that we need
to get the cheese just like this super
melty
Wow original one it looks kind of a leak
right Wow guys I did it I didn't think I
would be able to do it but I did it the
real test is does it taste like it we
don't know I'm gonna have my friends and
my co-workers reveal the truth I'm
nervous
[Music]
this thing itself is the size of an egg
mcmuffin bye-bye
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
your part so describe here that was my
part